If I could rework the entire business
model of Google,
I would get google to charge for their
search engine.
I think it's an outstanding product.
I acknowledge that.
I'll say it publicly.
I use it all the time too much.
I don't have a google account.
I'm very careful about that.
I don't have a gmail account and I don't
sign into google when I use the google
search,
but Google still knows me because I'm
really only on one or two computers.
If they're watching,
uh,
they will,
they will know.
A Google of course is always watching.
Um,
but the way to solve that is that
google,
the google search,
the google or the Google products are
free,
which means that they have to read that
their revenue is derived from
advertising.
The alternative would be to charge me
$10 a month,
say for all I can eat on the Google
search.
And in exchange for that,
they would say,
we will promise never to look at you
the,
there'd be no cookies,
no ways that they can survey what we're
doing.
They would do away with themselves as a
big data company.
The same is true of facebook.
I don't have a facebook account,
not because facebook's or bad product in
some way.
I think it's creepy,
but only because of that data practices.
If the facebook product was offered for
10 or $15 a month or whatever the price
was like spotify is,
it would be a much more attractive
model.
So I think that that is the challenge.
I'm not the only person to think in
these terms.
Ethan Zimmerman,
um,
who is a fellow at the Berkman Center
and one of the most articulate sort of
evangelists for the Internet,
at least at the beginning,
argues now that the free business model
was the original sin of the Internet.
And I think Ethan's choice of Biblical
language is appropriate.
It wasn't original sin,
it's corrupted everything else.
So I want to see Google charge for their
services and I think that they could
still be an incredibly viable company
after all,
what's wrong with paying with stuff?
Uh,
before this interview,
I paid for my lunch.
I paid for my taxi cab.
I didn't exchange my data for it.
That economy has worked well for
hundreds of years.
This new economy is creepy.
It's corrupted by the original sin of
swapping wonderful technology for data.